30 años después de su lanzamiento de
nevermind el álbum de la banda nirvana
sigue siendo uno de los éxitos más
importantes de todos los tiempos un
icónico álbum que marcó una generación
entera pero nadie más que aspen xerente
luego de tres décadas quién fue el bebé
de la portada dice haber sufrido daños
de por vida por lo que presentó una
demanda por explotación sexual
es preocupante saber que toda esa gente
vio mi pene de cuando era bebé
una vez estuve en un partido de béisbol
y en un momento fue como hey todas estas
personas vieron mi pene de bebé en main
event es el de está pidiendo 150.000
dólares de cada uno de sus acusados
entre los que están en universal music
group las leyendas musicales de it go y
kornílov al igual que el fotógrafo que
tomó la fotografía original
ahora muchos expertos legales son
escépticos sobre si la foto puede
considerarse como pornografía infantil
no parece haber una conducta sexual solo
porque la foto muestra un niño desnudo
no significa que sea pornografía
infantil
en ese entonces nirvana era una banda
relativamente poco conocida muy lejos
del éxito mundial que obtuvieron unos
años después el fotógrafo kirk weddle
dijo que le pagaron mil dólares mientras
que los padres de eulen que eran sus
amigos sólo recibieron 200 dólares por
la foto
alden que tiene tatuado el nombre del
álbum en su pecho ha posado en repetidas
ocasiones para recrear el icónico álbum